Republican Arizona Senator John McCain
was recently diagnosed with brain cancer
and it's been no secret that he's not
been thrilled with Donald Trump for some
time now I don't know if maybe this
diagnosis moved him to more of a no
holding back attitude maybe he's just
genuinely increasingly disgusted with
Donald Trump as I guess some of his
fellow Republicans are but he now is
directly going at Trump without even
having to mention his name by the way
for Donald Trump's multiple
draft-dodging deferments for his bone
spurs you'll remember that Donald Trump
once said he doesn't consider John
McCain a war hero because John McCain
was captured and held as a prisoner of
war and McCain is now going on the
offensive and if you don't remember the
Donald Trump draft-dodging thing Donald
Trump got multiple deferments from
Vietnam a four supposed bone spurs that
he had and later he didn't even remember
whether the bone spurs were in the left
right or both feet here's John McCain
interviewed on c-span in a retrospective
about the Vietnam War and without
mentioning Trump very clearly slamming
the president's draft-dodging mass
arrest demonstration Chicago that all of
us can look back and see on c-span but
it was a tumultuous time and most of it
was bred by the conflict and one aspect
of the conflict by the way that I will
never ever countenance is that we
drafted the lowest income level of
America
and the highest income level found a
doctor that would say that they had a
bone spur that is wrong that is wrong if
we're gonna ask every American to serve
every American should serve perfectly
true later on after the initial news of
these deferments draft-dodging
deferments from trump he clarified that
quote i had a doctor that gave me a
letter a very strong letter on the heels
of course it was not an army doctor it
was a doctor that donald trump's dad
lined up and right-wingers are flipping
out at john mccain who I guess is the
new enemy of the alt-right but McCain
said nothing controversial here there
his major hypocrisy on this issue by
Republicans by the way remember John
Kerry senator Secretary of State 2004
Democratic presidential candidate
military veteran he was feminized by the
right in 2004 for being this wealthy a
dude who spoke French and and and a lot
of it had to do with his wife's family's
money actually and he is the feminine
man as we've talked about before
meanwhile Donald Trump's dad pulls
strings to get Donald Trump out of
serving and then becomes this major
Chicken Hawk and rhetoric and maybe an
action will soon see and the right
absolutely loves him because all that
matters is this guy's on my side that
guy's not on my side so this guy's good
and that guy's bad and I will never
understand military members who support
Donald Trump he dumps on their service
he makes fun of people sacrifice he
dodges the draft multiple times he will
get many killed for political gain he
will use the military to oppose
constitutional protests like those of
the NFL's and it's disrespectful to the
troops as if it's some amorphous and and
singular group he lied and will keep on
lying about donating money to vet
veterans and many veterans love this guy
and what does it get us back to it gets
us back to what I just spoke about with
Josh Zepps do not waste time trying to
change these people's minds if it's
electoral results you want focus on
getting out the vote from people who
already understand logic and reason
because it is a waste of time to try to
appeal to these people elect orally the
caveat is and I know people get mad
whenever I say this I'm not saying don't
speak to or debate the opposition I'm
saying as political election strategy
don't waste your time and focus on
getting out the vote the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad